les autorités indiennes ont donné leur
feu vert à la reprise de certaines
activités principalement dans les zones
rurales sont concernés les services
commerciaux en ligne une petite partie
de l'industrie notamment dans l'énergie
et le bâtiment puis surtout un secteur
clé celui de l'agriculture et ses
activités connexes dont dépendent près
de deux tiers de la population active
ils ne peuvent pas lever le confinement
maintenant parce que le virus va se
propager lorsque les gens recommenceront
à travailler la seule raison pour
laquelle les agriculteurs sont désormais
autorisés à travailler et que si nous ne
travaillons par le peuple n'aura rien à
manger
l'assouplissement des règles est censée
atténuer l'impact économique dévastateur
du confinement un confinement depuis
près d'un mois qui a privé des centaines
de millions d'indiens de leur gagne pain
mais malgré l'autorisation la reprise de
certaines activités de nombreuses
entreprises restent fermés
on a d'abord pensé que le 16 mars le
gouvernement prendrait fin mais ce n'est
pas le cas et on nous a dit que le 20
avril certains secteurs rouvriraient
mais la réalité différente
que faire maintenant on ne peut gagner
de l'argent que si on nous permet de
travailler certains états et territoires
indiens dont la capitale mieux des lions
ont choisi de ne pas autoriser la
reprise partielle du travail en raison
de la hausse de cas de kovy 19
redémarrage ou pas de certains secteurs
économiques les recommandations restent
les mêmes pour les 1 milliard 300
millions d'indiens la distanciation
social port d'un masque ou d'une
protection sur le visage et pour
sensibiliser aux dangers du coronavirus
tous les moyens sont bons avec notamment
cette sculpture d'éléphants portant un
masque et des places et dans les rues de
la capitale de l'état du tamil nadu